in the stoic week handbook for 2015 they
give you these noontime meditations with
some really helpful suggestions for
thinking things through exercises you
might say and the exercise for day one
is runs like this take a few minutes to
think about the qualities you've come to
value in the course of your life however
young or old you are have you changed
your ideas about what is most important
in the course of your life as your
situation has changed do you think your
ideas have deepened down this topic over
time or not and then it goes on think
too about the people who have helped you
appreciate the importance of these
qualities and what qualities are ways of
life they've led you to value they might
be family members close friends or
partners work associates or people you
do not know directly but whom you
respect and admire and it suggests you
might like to make notes or pictures on
this and to you know chart things out
that's what I'm doing here in this video
I'm carrying out some reactions and
reflections every single day over the
course of stoic week I'm somebody who's
been studying stoicism for quite some
time but you know like anything
philosophical you never really get to
the absolute bottom of it you never
exhaust that there's always more to
learn so I'm really happy to have this
exercise to to engage with so have my
values of the qualities that I value in
myself and others changed over time yes
considerably and I'm a happier person
for it and I'm quite a different person
because of it the first thing that came
to mind is I was reflecting on this is
you know when I was in well my teen
years and and well through my 20s I was
somewhat of what you might call a
hothead and a tough guy am actually a
lot of the work that I do with anger
still stems from my interest in figuring
out what the hell was wrong with me what
the hell is wrong with other people in
the world that you know made me such
such an anger prone person
but it wasn't just anger was also you
know there was you know the greeks call
it feel Oh nikia this this is wanting
not to be so much right but wanting to
be on top wanting to be the one who's
acknowledged as being the best being
being right competitiveness we could
call it and I was very competitive in
part because you know it was connected
up with with issues of right and wrong
and what I thought was just and unjust
oftentimes I was quite off base about
those sorts of things and occasionally I
still am in my own life today as I as I
try it out through through bitter
experience but it you know i would get
involved in activities and I always
wanted to be you know on top I always
wanted to be number one and that led to
quite a bit of insecurity and bitterness
on my part because it's not possible you
know I was very fortunate in that I was
gifted intellectually so and I had I had
a um you know set of adoptive parents
who really took a lot of time and effort
to help me develop intellectually not
quite so much in figuring out the
psychological aspects of how to deal
with the fact that you know you're
running on all eight cylinders while the
school is only running on one or that
sort of thing or how to fit in but you
know when I would get tested as a kid I
was off the charts and I started reading
when i was when i was about three years
old in part because my mother worked
with me I started doing fairly high
level mathematics for a kid by the time
that I was four and five because my dad
worked with me and so you know i could
get ahead very easily in that I don't
know that I've a lewd it quite so much
because it was more in the areas where
there was a wider you know field that
that
I would compete against that I saw I saw
that is more valuable and I'm not quite
sure exactly where I picked it up it
might be from our culture it might be
from just the way I grew up in the
environment I grew up in but you know
toughness became something very
important for me particularly in the
years after my dad had died you know I
looked to essentially soldiers and and
warrior types as being my ideal so you
know in a certain way stoicism in a
misunderstood man or fit in with that
because you know when you think about
the the tough guy the warrior the person
who is willing to endure a lot who
doesn't you know allow their emotions
except perhaps rage every once in a
while to dominate them who approaches
situations in what seems like a problem
solving rational way yeah that that's
sort of a truncated version of Stoicism
it actually doesn't fit into the
philosophy as a whole you know we're
reading my case rereading Marcus
Aurelius this week and he is a great
example of a not only a you know
philosopher king but also a warrior sage
he's somebody who practiced the stoic
life while living in you know a military
manner leading campaigns that he didn't
want to have to do but he saw as needed
for the benefit of the Roman nation
which he was charged with so you know
all of that sort of you know these these
sort of two motifs of toughness and
competitiveness in in my life you know
they drove me through a lot of what I
was doing I would say that you know
there was also another motif which was I
was always trying to look for greater
meaning something that made sense out of
everything and that I could belong to
and I tried a lot of different things
and sometimes even coincide you know i
would say that one example of that is
when i joined the US military and I went
in to become a combat engineer with the
goal i actually sounds very very silly
at this point of ultimately becoming a
mercenary you know i thought that that
sort of life first of all being part of
you know the larger military and
defending the West against the east it
was a time of you know the Iron Curtain
and Warsaw Pact and then you know a life
of adventure with good friends there
were other guys involved in this sort of
prospect to all of whom I Bluffs lost
touch with except for one who now is a
blacksmith yeah you know this this was
for me something that gave meaning and
then I was very disillusioned when it
turned out that the military's very
different especially in peacetime then I
was I was figuring and then you know I
ended up going to college some place I'd
never intended to go to but I think you
know my my mother really wanted me to go
and I was kind of tired after I got on
the military working dead-end jobs and
there you know there was a chance to
succeed intellectually and one of the
struggles I had for a long time for for
me fortunately it's it's you know long
past was the kind of competitiveness
with the other graduate students and
even with young professors that having
some sort of you know intellectual
acuity allowed me to do I actually I'm
not very proud of the way I behaved as a
graduate student I was quite a jerk much
of the time and people put up with a lot
of nonsense from me that I don't think
they they really ought to have but I'm
really glad that they did I've actually
written some of them and apologized and
thank them for some of their guidance
that they showed me so that's a good
transition point to thinking about you
know what I value
today I would say that I have come to
appreciate the other the other virtues
if in my earlier life I was much more
about courage and temperance at least in
the sense of just self control over
bodily appetites and being able to work
out a lot and you know endure hardship
now I'm much more about practical wisdom
for an asus and justice and I think I
thought it was about justice in the past
but it wasn't at all yeah there were
glimmers I you know what other people
would do you know I would sometimes kick
against it but I could recognize the
rightness of it but it wasn't such a
important thing for me I was I was too
driven by these other passions and
driven by thinking that you can have
some of the virtues without having the
rest of the virtues so as I've gotten
older and as I've encountered and had to
work through quite a few setbacks in
life some of them physical some of them
family-wise some of them career-wise
right you know deal with various
challenges and become much more aware of
myself as a finite being whose potential
you know it can go this way or this way
but I can't choose all of them at the
same time I've really come to value
practical wisdom which is you know the
centerpiece of the virtues figuring out
what is best for us what is truly best
for us not just what we think at the
moment is best for us or what we tell
ourselves because the culture pushes
that on to us and it's convenient for us
or what's going to get us into a good
career track or or you know get us that
award or something like that what is
truly best for us and I think that in
order to exercise prudence you have to
learn to not be I don't want to say
black and white about things because
really things are much much you know
much of the world is in fact black and
white it's just a charmless girl where
you know the little bits look gray
because there's
black and white you know and little dots
next to each other but often times we
have to be much more flexible we have to
defer our judgments or we have to be
provisional in our judgments and then be
willing to revise them as we get better
information as other people say hey
you're off base here why don't you think
more about this we have to be willing to
do that and that requires a kind of
openness that is you know it's not
automatic especially after we've built
up habits of you know going our own way
and not listening to other people in
part for me that's that's made me a
better philosopher partly by stripping
away the wish to do much original on my
own part I have these you know great
thinkers like the Stoics for example who
I can read and marvel at and incorporate
and teach about and if I just do a good
job not screwing them up as I'm
portraying them that's enough for me I
don't need to say anything particularly
profound or original on my own part
because I can fit into this you know
there's larger universe this this realm
in which we have exposure to the riches
of millennia of texts and thinkers not
just in philosophy but in history and
literature you know we can't exhaust it
in a lifetime as a matter of fact that's
probably my well I have a lot of regrets
but that's probably one of my my biggest
regrets is how much time I wasted on
trivial things rather than rereading
Plato or rereading epictetus or
rereading Pascal and talking about it
with other people and teaching about it
so long entry I'm going to try to keep
these a bit shorter in the future that's
it for today
it's now day two of Stoicism week and
I'm looking at the noontime meditation
for the day they to the theme that they
picked is the classic stoic theme of
what is in our control or our business
and what is not in our control and the
suggestion is take a few minutes to
think in a specific way about what this
distinction would mean in your own life
you could begin by making two lists one
of things in your current life and
situation you can control by your own
actions and aspirations and one of the
things you cannot control you could then
examine the contents of the two lists
and think about which of these two lists
is on reflection more important and
valuable and then he asked how far do
your lists match the stoic distinction
between things that are and are not
within our power is summarized by
epictetus for example how far does it
match the stoic distinction between
virtuous actions and externals or
indifference such as health property and
social status so when I'm thinking about
that right now you know you can hear
some of the street noise outside the
building across the street from our
building there's somebody operating some
sort of circular saw which is making
quite a bit of noise people honking I
fine as a Content producer I'm a bit of
a perfectionist about wanting my videos
to have excellent zone quality which
they almost never really do and you know
so things like that have a tendency to
annoy me but if I apply this distinction
to to that I don't really have any
control over that environment the best
that I can do is to try to set things up
in such a way that I can shoot and then
I can get the material out there in a
timely manner to people who'd like to
see it and that's about as far as it can
go there's a lot of things that can go
wrong I'll say as well that the
technology and the place in which you're
shooting are often impediments to you as
well but they don't have to be great
impediments because what's most
important you know I guess that's what
the upshot of this is for
me what do I have control over I have
control over whether I do a video or not
I have control over whether I come to
the video well informed and having
reflected on what I'm going to say I
have control over whether I allow all
these these things to you know the
environment the acoustics of the place
which I'm still not quite used to the
way the microphone sounds the way the
the recording stuff works in terms of
apple products I don't have to let all
of that get to me because I can
concentrate on that the parts that I do
have control over whether I'm
knowledgeable whether I communicate
effectively whether I do the work that's
that's required or not and if I can keep
my my focus on those things and not
allow myself to get too distracted or in
my case quite often irritated by the
things that don't have control over i'm
likely to do two things one is to do a
better job on the video communicate more
effectively and the other is all
actually enjoy it more sometimes I
really enjoy the work that I do
sometimes not quite so much i find it an
annoyance or i find it you know
something i have to get through and
ideally you want to have a job where
you're doing what it is that you're well
suited for all the time and actually
enjoying it because it uses your talents
and your capacities so you know all of
that fits in there i would say another
thing too that I've been thinking quite
a bit about because i'm doing the stoic
week event in Milwaukee which is my
hometown originally but I haven't lived
here for 20 years I'm not sure how many
people are going to show up I'm hoping
that I don't have you know a tiny
audience because we booked a room that
can see 50 people and i do want to
videotape it i want to get some good Q&A
but you know then when i think about it
i've presented to
rooms of 200 people I've presented to an
audience as small as one person showing
up to an event and what really matters
is not how many people show up or even
you know how they react to the event I
don't have any control over that it's
instead what I bring to it what I
whether I prepare well whether I i
create the handout materials in a way
that's easy to follow whether I speak
well particularly given that i'm going
to be recording it whether I you know
talk about stoicism and how it can
improve our lives and lead us to
happiness in ways that can reach an
audience that isn't just there in that
room at that time on the other hand i
might get surprised and have so many
people showing up that they're out the
door and then that's a different kind of
thing that tends to make me a bit
anxious because then i have to think
about how I'm going to deal with that
but i don't really have to deal with
that that's not my business so to speak
it's not in my control
today it's day three of stomach week and
for the noontime meditation it is
focused today on mindfulness or
essentially paying attention to what's
going on with yourself with your
thoughts that you're having with your
emotional responses what's our desires
and aversions are being activated in
stoic terms so here's the prompt from
the handbook for today it says you've
already started monitoring your thoughts
actions and feelings and distinguishing
between things under your control if not
from this point onward during stoic we
try to catch the early warning signs of
strong desires or upsetting emotions
pause to give yourself thinking space
and to gain psychological distance from
your initial impressions if your
feelings are particularly strong or
difficult to deal with postpone thinking
about them any further until you've had
a chance to calm down which may be
during your evening meditation then try
asking yourself the following three
questions most importantly ask yourself
whether the things that are upsetting
you are within your power not and if
they're not accept this fact and remind
yourself such things are not
fundamentally important in the way that
virtue is second one ask yourself what a
perfectly wise and virtuous person would
do and faced with the same problem or
situation the stoics used the ideal of
the wise person or sage in just this why
do you think about someone you know
personally or somebody to know my
reputation who comes closest to this
ideal and take them as a model in your
reflections third ask yourself what
strengths or resources Nature has given
you to deal with the situation for
example do you have the capacity for
patience and endurance how am I using
those capacities help you help you deal
with this problem more wisely so right
now I would say if I have one main
problem it's not having enough time and
having made so many work commitments to
so many different projects that are I
think quite valuable but take an awful
lot to pull off successfully
I'm feeling overwhelmed you know a good
portion of the day and i found that
stoicism and stoic mindfulness
techniques can be quite helpful in
dealing with that in part because on the
one hand you know i think that advice
about you know telling those things look
you're just an impression of Phantasia
in stowing terms an imagination not not
the reality of things that you portray
yourself to be that is very powerful and
it gives you a distancing that's that's
quite useful that's talked about here in
the handbook and which is part of stoic
practice on the other hand the Stoics
don't say just push it away don't think
about it tell it it's nothing you are
supposed to come back to what you're
thinking about what you're feeling and
then examine it more closely later on
when you have a little bit more calm
when you have the capacity to to look at
it more we might say objectively I would
actually say more subjectively in a good
way because only the human subject can
look into himself or herself and really
see what's going on in the guts of the
psyche although another you know the
trained individual can often be quite
helpful in you know looking at what's
going on with you and how you present
and suggesting what might be going on so
when it comes to being overwhelmed you
know the some of the factors I just do
not have control over our the amount of
hours in a day and to some degree the
amount of energy that I have of course
if I screw around and putter and don't
get things done that's my choice and if
I fritter away my energy on on you know
useless pursuits like for example
watching a show you know watching One
Show
relax okay that's great watching you
know into watching as they as they call
it these days not so great and that
tends to enervate you rather than
energize you you know similarly if I I'm
not even tempted to do this but if I
were to go out and say I'm going to blow
off some steam I'm gonna go to the bar
and just get drunk well then if my work
doesn't get done I know exactly what
that is I have control over those
elements but I don't have control over
whether the technology cooperates with
me I don't have control over you know
how the environment works for my filming
and I've got lighting that I can i can
use but there's only so much that you
can do about noise and about sound and
things like that i have control over how
much effort I put in and whether I
structure my time thoughtfully or
whether I do things in a haphazard
manner that's less likely to get things
done so you know who would be somebody
who I might look to oh I'm a big fan of
Epictetus I keep reading and rereading
his discourses but Aurelius who is also
very influenced by epictetus is also a
great example as well because he was a
guy who really did not have that works
in the day for the job that he was
supposed to do and what I think about
you know in comparison trying to produce
philosophy content engaging with people
do the consulting work that I do get
some the academic writing done get some
popular writing done you know hold
events start building a new client base
out here all those sorts of things
really pale in comparison to running the
Roman Empire during the type of crisis
makes it you know puts it in perspective
so you know the third part what
strengths or resources have have I been
given to deal with the situation well
you know one of the strengths is indeed
in the teachings of Stoicism 11 of the
teachings of Stoicism it's a little soft
referential is you ought to have handy
some of the teachings so that when some
and comes up you're not left in the
lurch or scrambling and trying to find
where's the book you can say ah this is
what this is what applies in this
situation this is what can help me make
sense of it and not be so troubled or
anxious or scattered raped so that's one
strength that's one resource you know
there's also internal strengths and
resources you know patience to let
things sort themselves out over time the
let's call it diligence required to get
things done in an orderly manner rather
than trying to get them all done at once
and prudence you know practical wisdom
practical wisdom is one of those sorts
of things that it's not as if you just
simply have it and then you engage it
it's something that has to be built over
time and the more that you use it the
stronger it gets so you know every time
that I make a choice about should I
think about this prudently or should I
just react I'm deciding whether i want
to have more capacity to do that in the
future or perhaps less capacity or the
same capacity so you know when I even
want to think about it that way I end up
feeling much less overwhelmed with all
the stuff that I have on my to-do list
today is day 4 of stoic week 2015 and
the theme for today in the handbook is
virtue so there's an interesting virtue
and values clarification exercise for
the noonday reflection and it runs like
this as a first move in this direction
here's two exercises that might help
first use these questions to clarify
your core values what's ultimately the
most important thing in life to you what
do you want your life to stand for or be
about what would you most like your life
to be remembered for after you've died
what sort of thing do you want to spend
your time doing what sort of person do
you want to be in your various
relationships and roles in life that is
as a parent a friend at work or in life
generally and then it suggests you could
also ask how for you how far your core
values match what the ancient stoics
meant by virtue especially character
traits such as wisdom justice courage
and moderation and then suggest second
look at all your answers to the first
set of questions and ask how far your
real actions on a day-to-day basis match
your core values if they don't match
completely and it would be surprising if
they did think about ways in which you
could bring the two closer together
think of one specific activity you could
be doing but aren't which would help you
develop towards expressing your core
values or which would enable you to
express them fully so again really great
exercise a lot to think about there
what's ultimately the most important
thing in life to me I think at an
earlier stage I would have said
something like possessing wisdom or you
know something like having a great
career in philosophy you know writing
important works that advance the the
discipline and deal with if not
necessarily resolve problems that have
long Stan you know long-standing benben
puzzles for for philosophers but if I
had to put it in a word
now i would say persons i've come to
realize as time is going on i'm at the
midway point in my life and I've you
know met a lot of people and interacted
with quite a few many good many bad and
I have had children who are you know
quite a responsibility I've taught a lot
of students and it hit a lot of you know
people in my life exit this life at one
point or another and so I've become more
and more more and more conscious of
things that I was missing out on in the
past namely how important it is to
attend to and to appreciate the people
that we have and to engage in good
relationships with them and that
requires you know quite a bit on our
part especially in the society that we
live in today with a million different
distractions and frustrations and you
know we're scattered in all different
ways it's it's easy to start you know
losing track of what really matters you
know I could answer some of these other
questions but I don't want to get this
to I don't want this to get too long I
don't know what I would want my life to
be remembered for after I've died again
I wanted to leave behind a legacy in
earlier earlier years but as I you know
as I did more and more work in
philosophy I think I've come to the
point where i'm not very worried about
my own legacy and i'm more interested in
helping to carry on and initiate people
into a long-standing tradition that in
which a lot of the heavy lifting has
been done by other philosophers before
me including some of the present you
know great thinkers like say Alistair
McIntyre who are still around you know
there's been great thinkers down through
the ages and you know I could spend my
time trying to do my own thing and
probably not do it all that well or I
could
been my time you know really learning
what what Plato has to say really
learning what decart has to say really
learning what Hagel has to say and then
helping other people to grasp that as
well so I you know I think I'm not sure
that my life is going to get a Wikipedia
entry and maybe it doesn't need it but I
would like to have left behind a lot of
students and a lot of friends and family
upon whom I've made some sort of
positive impact not so much just on my
own part but by introducing them to the
great things that I value including
stoicism what sort of person do you most
want to be in your various relationships
and rolls and life as a parent friend at
work or in life generally wow that's an
easy one quite a bit different than I
still am I would like to be a much more
patient person a much more generous
person a much more just person in the
sense of not only you know doing the
right thing which is what I tend to do
but actually not having to force myself
to do when I recognized to be the right
thing because it becomes part of my my
nature that's something i have to work
quite a bit towards so if i look at my
answers to this first set of questions
and i asked how my real actions on a
day-to-day basis match this how can i
bring these closer together well clearly
i need to do some some more intensive
exercise when it comes to some of the
areas in which i haven't developed the
virtues like i would wish to and i also
need to start setting time aside to you
know spend less time focus on all the
minutiae of career stuff you know when
you're when you're in the position i am
where much of it is is you know me doing
it on my own or with fairly minimal
support from institutions you know i get
tied up in that sort of thing and and it
takes a lot of my attention away both
from the you know philosophical
some thinkers that I would love to be
able to spend a lot more time with and
with the people who I am helping to
communicate about this stuff to whether
through youtube or in my you know
speaking and face-to-face teaching in my
online classes in my philosophical
counseling all these sorts of things I
would like to be the kind of person who
is entirely available to use to use a
Marcel Ian word to the other person so
yeah I've got to do some work what would
what would be a specific activity that's
where it gets to the nitty-gritty isn't
it I think that one of the things i need
to do is what the Stoics counseled which
is have ready at hand some dog Mata that
is some some sayings some some sayings
that express core teachings or core
values about the sort of things that I
value so I can remind myself once I
start to become impatient with somebody
and finishing their sentences and not
waiting till you know they actually have
to say with what they have to say or any
of those others were things I can remind
myself that they are another self and
that I ought to be valuing them and that
that would be you know a great
expression of what it is that I'm
supposed to be about
today is day five of stoic week or
rather tonight is day five of stoic
weeks till you can tell by looking out
the window that it's now rather dark
because it's evening it's around six
o'clock at night so it's taken me this
long to get to the noon time meditation
for the day in part because I had a lot
of stuff going on that had to be
attended to today and my energy was a
bit low we had a great stoic week event
last night I'm going to be putting video
about that well by the time that you're
seeing this I've already put that video
out so no need for me to tell you about
it but it was well attended we had some
good discussions and I'm quite happy
with it as something that was put
together fairly you know fairly
last-minute in a new city you know going
up against as it turned out the
competition of a speaker cross that the
library was having so I had a lot of
opportunity to practice some of the you
know stoic dog matta the the things that
you tell yourself to try to put yourself
in the proper frame of mind when you
find that you're encountering
difficulties or emotions that are that
are troubling you know I was worried
that nobody was going to show up you
know for one thing but it turned out to
be to be a great time so let me get to
the exercise for today what they suggest
is an exercise based on the circles of
heracles who is a another stoic
philosopher whose works unfortunately we
don't have very much of so here CLE
suggested we thought we should think of
ourselves as living in a series of
concentric circles and that we should
try to draw the circles somehow toward
the center he explained that the right
point will be reached if through our own
initiative we reduce the distance of the
relationship with each person he also
suggests using verbal techniques such as
calling one's brothers ones cousins
brother and
uncles or aunts father or mother and we
could extend this further as as you know
they do in the stoic handbook to our
neighbors to co-workers to our fellow
citizens even the rest of the people in
the world thinking of them as being
closer to us in relation because
remember for the Stoics as epictetus
says duties are universally measured by
relationships so if I think of myself
just as a you know sibling or just as a
cousin or just as a co-worker I may
leave a lot of people out and so there's
you know there's two things we should
not only be thinking about those closer
more immediate relations that that we
encounter much of the time or that are
really formative for us or central in
our lives but we should try to extend
our matrix of relations out to consider
everybody as much as possible and then
like hirak Lisa jest try to pull them in
try to give those people who really
don't have any sort of you know justice
based claim stat you know on a different
kind of status we give it to them
remember you know that as I said with
Cicero one of the things that he was
impressed by with the stoics in his on
duties is the fact that beneficence is a
part of justice going beyond just the
rules to do more to be generous to be
kind in this case to be affectionate to
feel a sense of compassion or affection
towards other people so I always try to
you know talk a little bit about how
this plays out in my life I guess that
you know where this would come up for me
or I could really start applying this
more consistently I have a lot of
interactions if I want to have them with
people from all over the world because
of my youtube presence and also to a
lesser extent face
Twitter Linkedin Google+ I'm all over
the net and I have people you know email
me every once in a while just out of the
blue and say hey do you ever think of
this or like you'd like to you know
pitch an idea to you sometimes i even
have people who want my advice on things
and I do sometimes give you know free
free sessions you know which normally I
would I would I would you know be
charging for but I give them free to
people who are trying to do the sort of
things that I'm I'm doing you know with
producing content that is connected with
the intellectual life or the humanities
and they want to put it up on YouTube or
do something like that so what I have to
do if I'm going to follow this is be
much more consistent which I you know
admit I haven't been in treating
everybody you might say affectionately
trying to look at the good side of what
it is that they're doing even you know I
get a lot of emails and queries sort of
pestering me asking me to do this or two
that for them you know can you do a
video on this just why don't you drop
your whole production schedule and
create this video for me for free well
you know one way I could look at that is
instead of saying you know why are you
why don't you you know think about what
you're asking here I could say you know
it's really nice that they have that
sort of zeal for for learning that sort
of impulse and that they're willing to
email or message some person out of the
blue and say hey I would like to learn
about this do you think you could help
me out with that so that would be you
know really in accordance with the
advice that was given a little bit
earlier in the the meditation for the
day which is that you know Marcus would
talk about looking at each of the the
people and trying to see their best
traits trying to see how they actually
do participate in something that's
valuable rather than doing what's a lot
easier for us I think in our society
which is to look at the negative so a
lot for me to think about and mall over
I can't say that this is one of those
times where I can point towards a lot of
progress on my part unfortunately but
you know that means that I have some
work to do
it's day six of stoic week and the theme
in the handbook for the day is
resilience so what they provide you with
in the handbook today is a contemplative
exercise so that's what it would have
been called in ancient times you know
from from theoria contemplation an
active way of using one's mine nowadays
we would more call that visualization or
mindfulness because we have other jargon
that we like to use and it's it's an
interesting way to do things it's one
that I have myself started to
incorporate into my life starting with
stoic requests here and in part because
there is always fodder for for doing
this sort of thing because there's
always potential crises looming at least
in in my life and a life of people
around me so it suggests that what you
should do is visualize a a situation you
begin with something that's traumatic
you imagine the worst case scenario and
you you observe your emotions you start
thinking about your your reasons for
feeling those emotions and the thoughts
that accompany them and then you can
start to you might say deconstruct them
to determine whether they really are
rational or whether they're only semi
rational and you probably should you
know start to push them away and the way
that you push them away is by revealing
to yourself that these are not very true
and productive ways of thinking about
things when you do that you will
probably feel a sense of anxiety in part
because we often tend to push away any
sort of thinking about stuff that
bothers us and I will say that this is
an exercise that I've been doing in its
proper way for about a year and I've
been doing it in ways that are very
unproductive pretty much the whole of my
life I'm I'm a worrier I'm the kind of
person who does think about well what
could go wrong that's part of what makes
me a really great analyst when it comes
to
a curriculum design or putting together
a proposal I you know I'm the one who
sees well there's a crack there that
might need to be filled because you
never know what's going to come through
it so I'm the guy for that but then that
bears certain consequences from my own
life you know what could go wrong here
what could go wrong there and one of the
things that you want to be able to do is
think about what sort of resources you
would have to deal with the situation
and you know if you think about this in
terms of stoic philosophy the resources
that we want to bring to the fore are
the virtues or these capacities for
choosing the right thing we can remind
ourselves that we actually are free as
far as our faculty of choice goes and we
can decide we can determine to a certain
extent how we think and how we feel
about stuff we're not just stuck with it
the way that our thoughts and feelings
often tell us that that we are a lot of
the time when we're worrying and we're
sort of you know planning and problem
solving we think about external goods or
what for the stoics are actually in
difference for the most part property
wealth relationships those sorts of
things we think about those as what is
going to protect us from this you know
terrible thing that could happen but
those those are rather like dams that
can can easily burst and be flooded over
compared to what the Stoics call your
Faculty of choice your pro I race as
your ruling principle provided it's
properly developed you know so this is a
really great exercise to engage in I you
know recently did this myself in terms
of a theme that I've talked about a few
times already here about just how much
work is actually on my plate and whether
i can truly get everything done done
well satisfy the the commitments that
i've made to various people i'm working
a lot
he stays in order to do that but my fear
is even with that you know no matter how
much at work maybe I won't be able to
get things done or I won't be able to
get things done the way that that I want
them to with the quality or perhaps the
client or the the you know the viewer is
not going to be as happy about them but
again it helps me to remind myself that
a lot of this I don't really have much
control over i have control over how
well I do the work and whether I do the
work and if I make the time to do the
work rather than frittering it away with
other things which is quite possible
those things lie within my my sphere of
choice other things are really outside
of it and when I do that I I do in fact
notice a lessening of anxiety I can't
say that I i managed to dispel it
entirely as far as that sort of thing
goes I'm I've got a lot of work to do if
I'm going to ever be a stoic I have a
lot the road is very long for me but
it's a great exercise and glad that they
reminded us of it and gave some nice
structured ways to to apply it
it's day seven of stoic week 2015 so
things are coming to a close bringing an
end to the entire stoic week again and
then thinking about where we're going to
go from here the last of the meditations
or reflections has to do with nature and
the stoic view on not just the natural
world as we think about it but really
the whole the totality the cosmos and
everything in it and as he explains here
you know marcus being a essentially
orthodox stoic understood the universe
to have a rationality pervading it that
we human beings ourselves could align
ourselves with it's a little bit
different than say judeo-christian
conception of this or even a deus
conception where there's some sort of
deity whose not the world who gets
things started instead it's the world
itself that really is the divine and
what they suggest in the handbook doing
this time around is listening to the
meditation of view from above which is
really great I've used it a number of
times myself I like it as an exercise
started using it last year when I
downloaded it for the first time and
he's what he's got here in the handbook
is here's a pass at remark asst that
expresses vividly the theme of adopting
a view from above from a cosmic
standpoint Marcus's main focus here is
on standing back from your normal
perspective and seeing the relative
smallness and transience of human life
but elsewhere he also stresses the
positive ethical dimension of viewing
yourself as part of nature or rather
part of an organized cosmos a fine
reflection from Plato one who would
converse about human being should look
on all things earthly as though from
some point far above upon herds armies
and agriculture marriages and divorces
births and deaths the clamor of law
courts deserted wastes alien peoples of
every kind
festivals lamentations and markets this
inter mixture of everything an ordered
combination of opposites so you know to
bring these reflections myself to a
close when I do take this sort of point
of view I find it extremely helpful
because it puts things into a different
perspective much of the time you know in
large part because we need to be this
way in order to function well we focus
on what's before us we focus on a very
me centric perspective and that's you
know that's needed because nobody else
is going to do my work for me nobody
else is going to attend to situations
and figure out what exactly in them I
can bring to bear unless I'm under
somebody else's tutelage which I'm not I
you know I haven't been for a long time
and I'm you know running my own business
and carrying on all these sorts of
endeavors so I have to be rather
self-motivated but it's very useful to
be able to stand back from that and
think about the larger perspective that
that I find that that helps me not only
to deal with some of the stresses and
anxieties of the enterprises in which
I'm engaged in and you know some of the
interactions with other people that I
deal with it's also useful for me
getting a stronger sense out of what i
can do for other people what I can bring
to bear and how I ought to behave
towards them if I if I see things in the
larger perspective I might not just see
how people are connected with me but see
how they're connected with with each
other and with the larger world so a
great stoic week I had a very enjoyable
time doing the event and putting
together the cicero videos doing these
daily meditations I was not as active in
the class as I have been in the last
year but hopefully some of the other
stuff I did you know makes up for that
that virtual absence in any case
it's been a really great stoic week a
lot to think about and a lot to build on
so my thanks again to all of the people
involved over there at the University of
Exeter and organizing this for putting
together the blog years ago and
continuing it for for making sure that
this event occurs every year and just
you know keeping the whole thing going
it's really a great experience I would
love to see this happen for other
philosophical schools as well but the
fact that it's happening for stoicism I
think probably says something about that
philosophical school so on that I will